welcome to this video playing smile 64
from Italy Italian like at least okay
let's get funky again with this it is a
weird line yeah people are still taken
aback by it um yeah I think the caption
yep we already had that a couple of
times I mean on the channel a lot
against this opponent I actually have
never played him Queen a5 the CP 595 25
bishops III oh it's just taking them
well this just just this I don't know
really this is compensation once that's
difficult to believe I cannot I cannot
really believe that you know trying for
something direct here checkmate I one
that ever should just give the check and
Castle I Alice's check when he's got
bishops III this was a stupid move very
stupid move yeah okay maybe maybe it's
not it's not fatal and now I can
actually take you and I should check and
now cancelled yeah I don't know yeah
Bishop b5 wasn't a good idea we could
have played maybe just King evade and
then they stood the main threat and
bishops is frequently fibers threatened
was technically technically I'm not very
well founded at the m okay just
keep the Queen only to protect f2 yep
establishing the night down for the
moment
yeah and rook see one coming this is
meant to establish some control over you
five at least if it takes on c3 here i
also have rook see one I guess just
using the pen where are you going a
three let's create five I wonder if I
have queen bee five here Bishop's III
that's also Queen d7 this looks a bit
loose IAM or from provide taking on b5
not be five should be okay ready I can
take p2 down i was thinkin be one but
maybe
now still probably the best chance
taking on b5 taking on YouTube it looks
fairly active at least
well I really didn't are this one hand
but this I thought would be really
problematic because he's in an awkward
pinning situation here um retake see why
is my green trapped totally cannot
believe it ready
I can take you for here already oh I
really don't understand anything here
take you fall and then then my bishop is
hanging ok yeah well anyway i can i can
just take all this stuff take each seven
here maybe now that's not good idea see
form you know it blunder this but at the
moment I have it all protected young
this I can maybe just play hookey one
box is seven now he's got rocks
yeah probably not really terrible but I
didn't see it before hand rook c8 now
yeah I wookie one wasn't a good move
that's just far too superficial so I'm
tricky now maybe after I'd have still FC
form it suks if I did eat seven hangs
but we are my back rank is also not not
very not very very reassuring this this
is strange though now I can cover it
rather rather conveniently a thought I
need to and really challenge this bloody
quinium with Queen deform get the Queen
traded on 1995 coming yeah that that's
that's really good now that's very good
enough for what I get after Queen trade
I get 96 and or if he moves the Queen
somewhere i have night Andy 5c six young
man is should this should be really good
now should I trade come on let's trade
this act of peace
how to think how to do this rook could
be too I want to use the C porn maybe I
can protect d5 like that and just push
the sea por now okay sorry my voice is
really feeling you yeah this really
should it should promote you can give
give the night black resign but um yeah
I think in here in the opening there
were some points Knight g4 and now I
just I just must play yeah okay in
computer wants to play Bishop b5 I just
thought maybe just Quincy to or
something fun jack interesting okay this
is this possible maybe chat now this is
this is probably too strong for white
too much of an attack young interesting
so I was really here thinking I mean
that this might be a move and now my
problem is f2 hangs and there's a threat
of bishops III and Queen B 5 the
computer however stockfish shows that
Queen t2 is strong yeah probably i would
have found it simply by by the process
of elimination Bishop c3 Quincy three
then there's the rookies hanging
remarkable yeah yeah antium why this is
better again it's it's not not totally
easy to play but why this much better
yeah I don't know this was necessary
maybe not computer is just giving rook
ft 11.5
yeah it was probably not the most
precise way to play black has lots of
counter play but this was a strange move
really I didn't get it maybe he it was
more of a mouse lab or anything I
thought you would play against them the
sea poem like this still I have c4 but
this is not so convincing really young
Luke takes rook takes Queen takes at the
end i can take yeah but if this is
enough is questionable I cannot go as
somewhere here as I'm bacharach mated
difficult yeah well here here everything
is nice again I'm just in control again
and should win this okay thanks for
watching